this is the exact moment I know when I'm
going to fire a salesperson having
trained now probably 20 different sales
teams I've gotten pretty good at
recognizing sales Talent understanding
the extent of how much training can
improve someone the window and time that
I give people continues to shorten and
any kind of transactional sales that
take let's say two weeks or less in
order to close the deal you should be
able to tell relatively quickly in our
company if someone has a full sales
cycle and hasn't closed the deal they
usually get let go and the reason for
that is because the best sales people
I've ever had always close deals in that
first time period which means that this
person is not going to be one of them
and if I already know that they're not
going to be a star then I don't really
have a strong incentive to keep them
because they're going to decrease the
average productivity of the team and so
I want to always bring people who are
going to raise the bar not lower it and
so that's why I fire fast